is it not kind of speculative to study
these things unless you feel like you're
learning about math and that's important
to learn about five-dimensional FaceTime
and ads CFT where do you stand on that
well let me say instead of that specific
one let me just change your question a
little bit the questions are why do we
spend our time on theoretical questions
which are not directly relevant to our
universe that's I think you're giving
that through examples of for example
five Dimensions or anti-disitter space
or this on that if you were to write a
random theory in four dimension which is
consistent with Quantum field Theory
Finance rules of calculations and
everything good naively say okay it
could be like a gauge group with
billions of gluons and this and that and
this money particles and that many but
no no we only see very few particles
with very few forces around why now you
might say well this is metaphysics I
have no idea why I don't care about it